games games and more games Xbox game
pass is getting more of them every
single month new and old so here's a
look at some of the best ones to join
the services growing Library who knows
maybe you'll discover your next favorite
game
the acclaimed crpg series Shadowrun has
finally made its way to consoles and now
has a home on Game Pass including the
entire Trilogy Shadowrun Returns
Shadowrun dragonfall director's cut and
Shadowrun Hong Kong extended edition
Shadow run comes from the 1989 science
fantasy tabletop role-playing game set
in a future world where magic fantasy
and cybernetic creatures live and
co-exist at its core its cyberpunk meets
urban fantasy with a tinge of crime and
detective fiction sprinkled throughout
each game in the series stays true to
its RPG roots with branching narratives
and characters aplenty to meet all of
which is accompanied with turn-based
tactical combat filled with loads of
weapons and magical spells at your
disposal crpgs are few and far between
on consoles and thankfully they
redesigned the entire UI to be more
console friendly
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Shredder's
revenge is a pizza infused nostalgic
hell of a time but Pitch Perfect 90s
visuals and Aesthetics aside this game
holds its own in an era where
beat-em-ups aren't in the mainstream as
much Shredder's revenge feels like it
was ripped from the same days as the
TMNT arcade game and turtles in time and
it feels so good to just kick back pull
out some twin size and start swinging
Shredder's revenge features multiplayer
up to six players with the ability to
play as April O'Neil Splinter and the
unlockable Casey Jones He each character
has their own attributes and moves which
isn't novel by any means but I was
surprised how differently each character
felt and that there is a smidge of depth
Beyond just mashing buttons and jumping
it also features a totally killer
soundtrack it has two distinct modes a
basic story mode with checkpoints so you
can complete the game at your own pace
or a classic mode where you're given a
set amount of lives and you have to
complete it in one sitting like the
olden days
in a sea of bad royales where you drop
from the sky and go guns blazing naraka
blade point is a refreshing and
well-needed change of pace inspired by
the legends of the Far East noraka blade
point is a mythical 60 player PVP Battle
Royale with emphasis on martial inspired
melee combat magical abilities
Fantastical Mobility with just a
Sprinkle of some ranged weapons while
some br's can be a little slower and
methodical naraka leans into action by
giving players items like grappling
hooks to zip around the environment or
pull yourself into the fight you can
drop in with a three-player team and use
power's abilities to support one another
or there's of course a solo mode to
truly test your skills in there's
currently 10 Heroes to choose from with
the latest one being added earlier this
year
Shadow run wasn't the only Trilogy to
find its way on Game Pass recently the
second Ninja Gaiden Trilogy is also here
all wrapped up in the master collection
this is the definitive collection of
each installment including extra content
like DLC costumes game modes and other
playable characters these are some
fast-paced controller crunching action
games where speed and getting into that
flow state is absolutely key this
Trilogy was set in the same universe as
dead or alive so prepare to see a
reoccurring cast of characters from that
beloved fighting game if you're a Devil
May Cry or be a netafan and haven't
checked these out yet then consider
giving one of these a download
thankfully you can just download them
individually if you're just looking to
play one of them so that's pretty sweet
this is a very ninja themed Game Pass
list isn't it
omori is a cool stylized hand-drawn RPG
in the vein of the Mother series it's
Fantastical and Whimsy with terrifying
creatures despite its Whimsy Aesthetics
however the game tackles some heavy
themes including depression anxiety and
suicide so just keep that in mind Amore
also does a great job of shrouding
itself with Mystique the game's
description is quite cryptic and
mysterious mentioning that you'll be
navigating a mundane world to uncover a
forgotten past eluding that the path you
choose on your adventure can determine
your fate and the fate of others you'll
be gripping up with characters traveling
across vibrant worlds filled with plenty
of personalities but it doesn't stop
there as you'll be hurled into a
nightmarish surrealistic realm with much
darker foes and themes to face
foreign
the Crusader Kings franchise sees its
debut on consoles with Crusader Kings 3.
It's a grand strategy role-playing video
game set in the Middle Ages that'll have
you determine your Noble House's Legacy
it's a sprawling and simulated Medieval
World filled with historical characters
that can be romanced betrayed executed
or maybe even just Charmed a little all
in the process of claiming conquering
and ruling thousands of countries
kingdoms and Empires and oh does the
game get in depth including the ability
to even design your own faith it's a
game that simulates every little
decision you make into something that is
wholly realized and even when you make a
choice with a grave consequence failure
doesn't ever quite feel like the end
there's plenty of experimentation replay
ability to have with us especially if
you've ever fantasized about ruling in
medieval times thankfully the game's
very dense UI was redesigned for
controllers and Maui wawi then manages
to pull it off
chorus is a bombastic space shooting dog
fighting action adventure where you play
as Nara a living weapon on a quest to
take down the dark cult that made her
considering she was created by a dark
cult Nara also has to face her haunted
past in a journey of redemption you'll
fly through sprawling Space Station's
bizarre planes of existence and thrust
into zero g dogfights in the midst of
frenetic fast-paced action all the while
upgrading your ship with an array of
different weapons and other mind-bending
abilities including teleportation and
telekinesis
so this isn't just your regular old
space flying shooting because you got
like brain powers and stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it may be from 2017 but there's no
excuse to sleep on one of the most
ambitious entries in the Assassin's
Creed franchise Assassin's Creed Origins
is the first one to make a major shift
in the series and introduce RPG elements
like leveling and skill trees a decision
that has remained a Mainstay in the two
preceding installments it's also set in
ancient Egypt where players can parkour
their way around right up beside a
pyramid if you wanted given it was the
first RPG in the series Origins
instilled a heavy emphasis on side
quests as well as leveling systems and
given its name origins it serves as an
origin story for the hidden ones the
forerunners it's the Assassin
Brotherhood
all right BIM Bam Boom there you go
hopefully something on this list tickles
your fancy and if not there's a bunch of
ninja stuff on it like Ninja Turtles and
Ninja Gaiden and the Morocco blade Point
has ninjas so yeah good time to like
ninjas if you're a Game Pass subscriber
we make these videos monthly so if
there's a specific game you love on Game
Pass make sure to drop in the comments
Below in case we haven't mentioned it
yet or you know just to share with
others and if you happen to check out
one of these games let us know as always
I'd like to try and challenge folk to
pick a game they normally wouldn't try
because why not that's the beauty of
these services to just try and taste
stuff like Kentucky root zero give it a
shot you never know alright kids be well
till next time see you later
[Music]
thank you